[Musique]
aujourd'hui c'est la première édition de
l'événement échappé verte donc qui est
une journée pour découvrir la zone de
protection naturelle agricole et
forestière du plateau de Saclay donc
cette zone c'est 4115 hectares qui ont
été préservés de l'urbanisation donc ils
sont constitués 2500 hectares d'espaces
agricoles et puis
1640 hectares d'espaces naturels et
forestiers et donc aujourd'hui ce qu'on
a fait c'est que on a emmené donc les
habitants donc beaucoup de familles et
puis quelques étudiants du plateau donc
on avait 450 personnes inscrites donc on
les a emmenés sur un parcours de 10 km
un escape game au cœur de la zone de
protection pour découvrir cet espace qui
est vraiment à proximité de ces nouveaux
quartiers et puis donc là l'après-midi
c'est plutôt un village festif avec des
animations autour de l'agriculture de la
transition écologique pour voilà prendre
du temps et puis découvrir les produits
locaux et puis tout ce qui se passe sur
cette zone de protection
nous l'équipe d'organisation on est
vraiment content de l'ambiance très
joyeuse très très festive et puis on a
vraiment des retours très positifs des
personnes qui ont fait l'Escape Game qui
qui ont pu faire beaucoup de
d'animations sur le parcours des jeux et
puis découvrir un peu mieux les
différents milieux naturels les types
d'exploitation agricoles entre des
exploitations plutôt céréalières des
exploitations très diversifiées avec du
maraîchage et puis voilà passer par ces
lieux qui sont qui sont assez
remarquables dans le patrimoine du
plateau de Saclay
[Musique]
dans les prochaines perspectives sur la
zone de protection naturelle agricole et
forestière on a le lancement la révision
du coût du programme d'action qui est en
fait un programme qui regroupe tous les
acteurs une trentaine d'acteurs en fait
pour valoriser et préserver ces espaces
donc on termine le premier programme
d'action et là cette journée c'était
aussi pour marquer le lancement de toute
la concertation qui va avoir lieu
pendant la prochaine année pour définir
avec tous les acteurs du territoire les
nouveaux enjeux ce qu'on veut ce qu'on
voit pour valoriser cet espace et puis
du coup botter un nouveau programme
d'action à la fin de l'année 2023
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]